[Musique]
bonsoir ciao ortel merci d'être avec
nous on dirait que tu as tes france
adore ça devait être un coup d'envoi
plutôt enthousiasmant enthousiasmé pour
les démocrates et pof patatras des
couacs quel est le poids qu est ce que
ça dit aujourd'hui je pense que c'est un
développement malheureux pour le parti
démocrate qui as est humilié depuis la
nuit de l'élection 2016 lorsqu'il a
refusé d'accepter l'élection de donald
trump aujourd'hui bien des heures après
qu'ils auraient pu et dû être capable de
déclarer un gagnant dans un processus
très simple ils sont dans un état de
chaos c'est malheureux et je ne pense
pas qu'il puisse se rétablir
alors effectivement la portée de ce
couac et est importante puisque on le
disait c'était peut-être une occasion
pour les démocrates alors que le procès
en destitution semble pas avoir récolté
les fruits qu'ils souhaitaient est ce
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va
leur coller à la peau pour cette
nouvelle campagne présidentielle selon
vous je pense qu'on peut observer un
phénomène unique en ce moment dans les
politiques américaines fut un temps le
parti républicain et le parti démocrate
avait le monopole des électeurs mais
avec le développement des technologies
sociales des réseaux sociaux
les électeurs sont de plus en plus
indépendants donc ce qui est se consacre
uniquement au parti démocrate ou parti
républicain sont vouées à l'échec c'est
pour ça que donald trump a gagné et
c'est pour ça qu'aucun démocrate qu
aucun candidat n'est sorti en dehors du
parti démocrate
aujourd'hui clairement comment peut-on
expliquer cette malchance shoretel on
est quand même en 2020 un bug de cette
nature là pour une élection aussi
importante vous comment vous vous
l'expliquer il ya toujours des aspects
cachés
je pense que ce qu'hillary clinton
michelle obama veulent c'est qu'on aille
les chercher et qu'on dise qu aucun des
autres candidats ne sont à la hauteur
cette débâcle semble suggérer que un
outsider serait peut-être la personne
idéale
vous pensez qu'il pourrait y avoir on va
pas se développer la théorie du complot
ici mais vous pensez qu'ils pourraient y
avoir une forme de conte plan à vous
entendre que ça ne pourrait pas être
qu'un hasard sais c'est que vous êtes en
train de nous dire ça paraît incroyable
lorsqu'on étudie l'histoire des
primaires de 2016
il est authentique
il est sans aucun doute frais que
hillary clinton a trouvé un accord avec
le parti démocrate pour qu ils avantages
et c'est cela qui a mené à sa défaite
extraordinaire en 2016 je pense que
depuis elle meurt elle ne se calme pas
et elle a dit qu'elle l'a a été élu en
tant que présidente
donc on peut vraiment croire qu'elle
espère être de retour sur la scène
politique et qu'elle fait tout son
possible pour pouvoir prendre les
devants sur les autres candidats et
c'est une hypothèse qui pourrait vous
paraître crédible son retour d'hillary
clinton sur la scène des démocrates
chic
pour obtenir l'investiture démocrate
c'est certain mais donald trump à mon
sens la réduire en poussière
elle a déjà perdu au niveau présidentiel
et je ne pense pas qu'elle écoute même
si elle fait mine d'écouter le peuple
je pense que dans le monde demande aux
hommes et femmes politiques qui a d'être
plus honnête d'être plus authentique
on ne veut plus de ces technocrates qui
disent tout savoir mais qui ne savent
pas grand chose alors une chose est sûre
c'est qu'il ya un gagnant dans tout ça
c'est donald trump qui lui voit là
ironise aujourd'hui par twitter à ce
quoi que démocrate
tout semble à nouveau lui sourire
clairement donald trump une célébrité
mais également l'un des usagers et des
réseaux sociaux les plus efficaces de
l'histoire de ce média et il a beaucoup
d'argent pour sa campagne et je suis
certain qu'ils sont prêts à mettre en
place toute forme de publicité
il a beaucoup de succès notamment pour
une publicité récente et face au
désastre démocrate à san francisco bâti
mort et dans d'autres états et villes
contrôlées par les démocrates
la situation se présente très bien pour
donner 30 il va détruire tout autre
candidat lors des élections
merci beaucoup de charles martel d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
merci à vous